well I would judge myself to be I'm an
independent I don't necessarily Sam a
Denmark Democrat or a Republican and
American terminology but I do believe
that I do believe in the basic goodness
of man and I don't appreciate you know
the fear-mongering negative Hobbesian
view that a man is basically a beast to
be contained and to be wary of I think
that kind of thinking gets into a lot of
trouble if you're a political leader or
a political follower so I tend to
believe more but not in a naive way and
in the better side of humanity I believe
that politically anybody who wants to
really honestly communicate information
and for minute to cape people build
their awareness about issues in a solid
way that be somebody and do it in a real
voice and not be the classic politicians
sell out of looking to do anything for
votes I think America a lot of America
would agree with me on this and that
there's really a dearth of candidates
today that people would think maybe feel
that way
you